My guest this
week is the England
Rugby player, Maro Itoje.
He's tackled players on
the pitch and politicians
to try and help poorer children.
I want to ask him what
fires him up the most
and how do you prepare to run at someone
and tackle them?
Thank you so much for being here.
It's lovely to have you in the studio.
And I thought I'd start just,
I'm someone who studied
politics at university
and I know you also studied it
and have a big interest in it.
And I wonder now you're a sports star,
how political are you allowed to be
or how much is that part of who you are?
Well, I guess there's no real limit
to how political you wanna be.
I guess it's down to, you
know, individual choice
and freedom and how much
you wanna, you know,
delve into that world.
You know, politics as you said,
is something I studied at uni.
I did it at secondary school as well.
And even since graduating, it's, you know,
it's something that I've always
had a keen interest in.
I think it's in our minds a bit more
about sports stars and politics
because of the Men's World Cup
and what's been going on or
what's not been going on there.
And I wonder with that and that discussion
around that whole piece, you know
do you think it is actually important
for sports stars to stand
up and to make some noise
about issues that they care
about and about human rights?
Yeah, so I do think it's
important for athletes,
sports stars to, you know,
have their opinions heard
as long as, you know, they
have an opinion on it.
I'm not too comfortable
with the rhetoric of stars
or sports stars or athletes
being forced to take positions
that they're not comfortable with.
Or maybe they just don't
have an opinion at all.
But by all means, if there is
something that you believe in
if there's a, you know,
a stance or a position
or you know, a campaign that
you want to be involved in,
I think athletes should
feel emboldened to do so.
So there's a change isn't
there on that front.
And it was interesting, Gary Lineker
was on this program not long ago,
and he was saying he feels bad
for athletes and sports stars in some ways
'cause they can't win.
If they try and say something, you know
they get told, get back in
your box, perhaps by some
especially politicians may say it,
if they don't say something
they can also be attacked for that.
So it's quite a difficult
terrain in some ways.
It is, it's not easy.
And I think the best way
of navigating that
space is just try to be,
you know, authentic.
I think if you are authentic,
whether people like it
or they don't like it, at least you know
you are authentic to yourself
is when perhaps you jump
on a campaign because it's
popular or you are, you know,
you don't really know
what you're talking about
with regards to a certain issue or topic.
That's when it can be a
little bit wishy-washy.
But I think if it comes
from an authentic place
and you can always tell if it
comes from an authentic place
then by all means go ahead.
Well, do you follow football?
Is that allowed as a rugby star?
I'm an Arsenal fan, I'm
an Arsenal fan, so...
I never presume anything.
It's not always the
same groups that follow
the same things and the same interest.
But I mean, do you think
the England team have been,
the England men's team
have been bold enough?
We saw the German team put
their hands over their mouth
in reference to Qatar
censorship and all of that.
I think the men's football team,
and not in only just now,
but if you look at, you know
what they've done over the
last 18 months, 24 months
in some of the positions they've held
across different campaigns, I think
they've done a lot to push
the conversation forward.
I think they've done a
lot to raise awareness
or, you know just try and
move the needle a little bit.
You can always make an
argument that you could do more
you could do less, but the focus should be
on the people who are
organizing the event.
The focus should be on
the administrators to
make whatever stance that they wanna make.
I think, you know, I think
they have a track record
of doing good and, you know
standing up for things they believe in.
You did step into British
politics a little bit
with a small 'p' during the lockdown,
the covid lockdowns.
When you talked about the need
for children to have access to laptops
and to bridge that digital divide
when we were having schools shut
and education was being interrupted.
Why did you choose to do that
and and how did you find that experience?
I guess why I chose to do it,
it was brought to my attention.
This campaign, I guess,
you know, this campaign
wasn't started by me,
it was started, you know
there's been a lot of
people who've been doing
some good work in that
space, but essentially
there was the gap between
the haves and the have not's
was getting wider and wider
with regards to children's education.
And education is often what
we talk about in society
as you know, the great
leveler is the tool we use
for social mobility, is the
tool we use to, you know
to get people out of poverty.
And what was happening in that situation
in lockdown was those who had money,
who could afford data, had
iPads, had computers, laptops
et cetera, were able to
continue with their education.
And those who didn't were falling further
and further behind.
And, you know, the people
who were falling further
and further behind were the
exact people who, you know
we needed to help, who needed education
perhaps more so than others.
So that was, you know, the...
The driving force.
The driving force behind myself
getting involved in that campaign.
And how was the experience?
It was, you know, it
was a cool experience.
It was good.
It was nice to know that
you're having an impact
on some children's lives
in however small of a way
Do you like, what's the latest on that?
I mean, I know we're not in
lockdowns anymore, thankfully
but that's been a concern, hasn't it?
The exacerbation of inequality
and we're starting to
see some of the results of
what happened to children
especially during that time.
Do you have any update on that?
Do you stay in touch with it?
Yeah, so the digital
divide, obviously it's
in a slightly better
position now because children
are back at school,
they're attending classes,
they're, you know normal
school life as it were
has resumed, but you know,
the digital divide is still
something that is ongoing.
The then education secretary of of the UK,
Gavin Williamson, high
profile British politician,
he confused you with a
different black sports star
the footballer from Manchester United
England National, Marcus Rashford.
Do you remember when you heard about that
where you were and what your reaction was?
Yeah, it was all a little
bit odd to be honest.
So I think I was at home and then I just
noticed my phone was like
pinging off in notifications.
Yes.
And I was a little bit
confused what was going on
so then people started sending me articles
then I looked at what was going on.
Yeah.
So then it all started
to make sense to me.
And I mean, were you dismayed?
Were you shocked?
I mean...
So yeah, it was all very, very surprising.
It was all very surprising.
He, you know, the story
was that he, I think it was
had undertaken an interview
and he confused me
with Marcus Rashford or vice versa.
I can't quite remember.
So yeah, it was all a bit surprising.
But he did, you know,
he called me thereafter, we spoke.
He apologized.
What was that conversation like?
It was fine.
Okay.
He was fine.
He called, he said it was,
you know, honest mistake
and he hopes I took no offense to it,
but he said it was a long
interview and he, you know
just messed up his words.
Right. Okay.
Well it's always good
to be able to ask people
when they've been in
the middle of something,
how it was for them.
Let's talk about what you do do
which is obviously play rugby
at the highest possible level.
I love getting into which
we're gonna get into,
what people eat just generally
and I know you have to
eat certain things to get
through this and keep up a certain level,
but how do you prepare
before a tournament?
How do you prepare?
I guess it happens in many stages.
I guess before a tournament.
I think the first part of preparation
is physical preparation.
So getting yourself in
the right physical prep
and, you know, every
athlete that would look
a little bit different.
But for me that involves
a load of fitness work,
a load of strength work.
I was fortunate enough to go to Portland
this summer with Under Armour.
We did a little pre-season camp there.
Just getting the body
right, recovering well,
I'm exposing myself to new different type
of training methods, but yeah, it's just
a mixture of physical preparation.
Yeah.
Mental preparation.
Then once that's done, you know,
the team gets together and
the team trains to get going.
What's the mental preparation like?
Well, it's mainly around
like performance really.
So it's for me, so when I
mentally prepare for games
it's visualizing what
situations may happen.
It's, you know, getting
myself emotionally right
for games, you know
rugby is a very emotional,
is a very emotional game.
In what way?
I wouldn't necessarily
have thought of that word.
It's when I say emotion
like it's not normal to,
you know, run at people.
It's not normal to hit people.
It's not normal to, you know,
get in a scrum and launch
yourself at someone else.
So it's, and all those actions, you know
for it to be effective, you know,
you need to have a
certain level of emotion
in that you need to care
about what you're doing.
There needs to be like a,
it is not just something, you
know, just sending an email.
Yeah.
It's a much more emotive sport.
Is there anyone in public life or famous
that you've ever thought
that would be quite good fun
to tackle?
Well there was, I'm pretty sure I remember
I think there's a clip of Boris Johnson
tackling a kid.
There is.
Running with a rugby ball.
Which was an interesting look.
Yeah, I think he either tackled him
or ran completely over him.
Yeah, he made sure he beat him.
He definitely beat him for everyone.
Yeah, he beat him.
But who would I like to tackle?
I'm not sure, you know.
But it sounded like
you wanted to take him,
take on Boris Johnson at
that point for that kid.
Maybe, maybe, the kid would tap me in,
tap me in, I'll help him out.
But I don't know.
Yeah, I don't normally...
Think of it like that.
No, no. Fair enough.
You talk about children
and the next generation.
I know you were 11 when
you started playing
and things changed, like you're talking
about your nutrition as well
and there has been a lot
of talk lately about safety
and also in particular headgear
and how to protect players,
professional players and
younger, to protect their heads.
Are you concerned about
that and some of the issues
that have been raised about concerns
about long-term memory issues and the need
for helmets of some kind?
I think, you know, as
a player you have to be
or you don't have to be
but it is more than
reasonable to be concerned
about the long-term effects of the game,
especially in this current
climate where it's, you know
come to the forefront and it's,
you know, in the news a lot
and when we have former
players who've come out
and said or come out and you know
they now have issues which go back
to their playing days
resulting from concussion.
So it is more than sensible or reasonable
to be concerned with that.
What I would say, and
the only caveat to that
which makes me more
comfortable with, you know
continuing to play rugby is, you know,
the protocols and systems
that we have as players now
in comparison to, you
know, the early 2000's
the early 2010's is way different.
Is it?
Way different in terms of even not only
the processes, but in terms of the culture
in and around concussion
is totally different.
So I started playing
rugby in 2006 at my school
and probably from about 2006
to about 2013, 14 or so,
what I experienced was
the culture within rugby
that the concussion wasn't
really seen as a serious injury.
So if someone was to,
you know, get concussed
or get knocked out on the
field, it was almost seen
as an act of weakness for
them to come off the field
as a result of their head knock.
However, now it's almost
the complete opposite.
Once someone has a head knock, you know,
your teammates are no longer telling you,
"Hey, come on, get up,
get up, we need you."
They're thinking about that
person or that individual first.
They're saying, "No, you need to get out
because you need to look after your head."
So even the culture in and
around the conversation
has shifted immeasurably
and in addition to that
more science, more medical research.
So, you know, I recently
went through a concussion
protocol last summer,
so I'm quite familiar
with the process and it's
very, very thorough now
in comparison to what it was.
Do you think helmets should be the norm?
Well, you know I'm no
scientist, I'm no doctor
so I'll just caveat that with
regards to anything I say.
But not all scrum hats are proven to
stop concussion or reduce concussion.
I know there's a scrum hat
on the market now that makes that claim.
However, I'm not too sure on,
you know, the actual, you know
scientific research behind it.
So it is not as easy as
saying wear a scrum hat
then that reduces your
likelihood of concussion.
So it's a bit more complicated than that.
The women's game, the women's rugby game
which is coming up just
like, it's actually
probably behind where the
women's football game is
in terms of it's still
reach and popularity.
But there was a piece I
read recently which said
that for the first time ever
the men's game could
learn perhaps something
from the women's game when it comes
to how many head injuries or
head assessments there are
just because of playing
properly and you know,
doing things in a certain way.
I wonder what you make of the women's game
in comparison and also
the influence of that?
Is that something that
features when you are thinking
about how to play and the team?
The two very different, you know,
the two, obviously we both play rugby
but the two very different
styles of the game
and are there things that we can learn?
Of course there things that
we can learn and vice versa.
But you know, what I think
has been amazing has been
you know, the growth of the
women's game over the last
10 years in terms of skill,
in terms of participation,
in terms of viewing.
Recently there was the, you
know, women's World Cup.
Yeah.
And it was in New Zealand and you know,
the amount of people that
I knew that were waking up
at like 5:00 AM, 6:00 AM.
To watch their game
and to see their growth even in England,
has been amazing.
You know, the only shame is
that it was in New Zealand.
If that World Cup was in England
or in a time zone which
was a bit more friendly
to you know, English viewers
I think we would've seen
a similar phenomenon
to what we saw with the women's football.
We'll see how that goes.
Just on the point of view of safety,
not necessary to do with
concussion or head wear,
do your family struggle to watch you play?
Do they get nervous about
you getting hurt still or...
I don't think so.
I know you're at the top of your game.
Yeah, I don't think so.
It used to be my mom, but now...
And did she find it difficult?
I think she used to find
like the collisions,
like yeah, like made
her wince a little bit
but I don't think so.
They don't express to me
that anytime I'm injured
they're always like, "Oh
be careful, be careful, be careful."
But I don't think they struggle too much
with that aspect of the game.
They come to pretty
much every game though.
They do? Okay.
So if they do struggle with them
it's not stopping them from
coming to watch the games.
What would you say the culture
of the rugby community
is like as a player?
You know, we hear a lot about football,
we hear a lot about abuse,
a lot about things needing to improve.
Do you think Rugby's has
got it in a better place?
I think rugby is miles ahead of football.
I think rugby, you know, you
can never go to a, you know
I'm an Arsenal fan, you
can't go to the Emirates
and have Arsenal and Tottenham fans
sitting right next to each other
and expect a fight not
to happen or, you know
the police not to swarm in, you know,
you can go to Saracens,
our local London rivals or Harlequins,
you can go to any Saracens
Harlequins game, you know
Saracens fans will be sitting here.
Harlequins fans would be sitting here.
And that's the same with,
you know, international rugby
and with international rivalry.
So it was England - Wales
in the football recently
if that was in rugby, you know
you have English fans sitting
here, Welsh fans sitting here.
They'll always be drinking
together, laughing together.
That's happened a lot,
England and Wales in Rugby.
You know, they'll both be fiercely
supporting their teams, but the, you know
the dynamic and the whole
atmosphere is totally different.
Why do you think that is?
I mean there's that quote isn't there?
I always get it wrong.
So I've written it down.
"Football is a game for
Gents played by hooligans
and Rugby's, a game for
hooligans played by gentleman."
I mean, I don't know
if that ever rang true.
Yeah, I don't know.
I don't know.
That's the old adage, isn't it?
Yes.
But I don't know, I think
the spirit within rugby
is just totally different
especially amongst the supporters.
I think Rugby's supporters
perhaps go to games
to have a good time as opposed
to go to games to, you know,
hurl abuse at one another.
Maybe that's probably the key difference.
Yeah.
But it's just interesting
how it's grown up
completely differently in that way.
And why that is, I mean,
do you think more kids
also should be exposed to rugby?
You're talking about the
digital divide, but you know,
especially in the UK,
especially in England
you know, there's a real class divide
about who gets to play
rugby some of the time,
not all of the time
but football is generally
offered at all schools.
Rugby is not.
Yeah, rugby needs to grow,
rugby needs to grow and you know,
rugby needs to look at
ways in which it can expand
into different markets, different
areas, different schools,
different demographics, because you know,
rugby as a sport
it needs to grow and it needs to go
into these markets that
don't typically play rugby
or aren't typically, you
know, associated with rugby
in order to achieve that growth.
Yeah, I think rugby is very
good at singing to the choir.
Where I think rugby can improve
is in its outreach, is how it's marketed,
in how it tries to get new
people to come into the fold.
Yeah. I mean it'll be
interesting to see how
that changes also maybe
with the women's game
and the appeal of how that moves on.
You've said you don't
wanna be a pundit actually
and I'm not trying to bring
your career to a close,
but what's that like though
when you try and think beyond,
because you obviously do
have a lot of interests
and it isn't inauthentic for
you to share views on things.
What else takes your
fantasy do you reckon?
Oh, what other things am I interested in?
Yeah, no, to perhaps
be for the future if...
Oh well I think, you
know, I think retirement
from rugby is something
that is in the back
of pretty much all rugby
players or all athletes minds
and I think it's important
to have a think about it
and you know, so you can
plan that next stage.
I'm a big African art enthusiast, you know
the dream one day will
be to have a gallery,
African art gallery.
So hopefully we can make that happen.
I wanna do a bit more philanthropic work.
I want to be involved
in a bit of business.
I probably want to go
into business after rugby.
So how old are you now?
I'm 28.
And when is a retirement age ish?
From, I'm thinking mid thirties.
Okay.
I think like 35.
And then you're done.
I think that'll be a
good time to wrap it up.
So I've still got a little bit
of running in these old legs yet.
Yes, you do.
And you've got some work
to do before France.
We do.
It's lovely to talk to you.
Thank you so much.
Oh no, thank you.
Thank you very much.
And thank you for being with us.
Until we meet again,
take care and goodbye.